state attorneys general who are the top
law enforcement officials in each state
have the final say on which cases to
pursue or not that power has not gone
unnoticed by lobbyists CBS News got an
inside look at one lavish retreat where
businesses and trade groups paid for
access some of these companies are under
investigation by state attorneys general
but still give large donations so they
can get one-on-one time to AG's to state
their case Nancy Cordes is here with a
look at what those officials get in
return Nancy good morning interested to
see this it's right and you know it's
all perfectly legal for these companies
to give i popping sums to the partisan
groups that help those AG's get elected
and re-elected in exchange those groups
arrange luxurious private gatherings
where the officials and the donors can
get to know each other far from the
holes of government rubbing shoulders
with a State Attorney General doesn't
come cheap to get an invite to this
four-day retreat lobbyists had to fork
over 125 thousand dollars the dress code
resort casual selling access to events
like this one has helped the Republican
attorneys general association or ragga
raise more than 20 million dollars in
the last year and a half twice as much
as their democratic counterparts CBS
News reviewed 88 donations of $50,000 or
more to ragga and found that more than
half of those donors had matters under
consideration by a state attorney
general or had recently settled others
needed help from the AG community the
NRA for instance made a seven hundred
thousand dollar donation to ragga four
weeks after the Las Vegas shooting it
was a six-fold increase from the
previous year and came as even some
Republicans were calling for new gun
control measures this ban on these bum
stocks should be codified one month
later 24 of the 27 GOP attorneys general
wrote this letter urging Congress to
pass
sealed carry legislation top priority
for the NRA
the NRA told CBS News it did not discuss
the letter with ragga and gave
generously turaga simply because the NRA
supports organizations that work to
elect pro-second amendment candidates
the major concern from my perspective is
that this is completely behind closed
doors Marquette University's Paul
nollette has studied the role of state
attorneys general if the public doesn't
know what the connection between the
money coming in and the policies or
Investigations going out are then it
really raises some questions and the
more money these lobbyists shell out the
more access they get at swanky golf
resorts like this one in Pinehurst North
Carolina $50,000 entitles them to
so-called issue briefings one-on-one
with Republican AG's Kiawah Island Golf
Resort is a coastal retreat of
spectacular natural beauty the most
luxurious gathering we saw was on Kiawah
Island in South Carolina an event so
exclusive it's not even mentioned on
raagas website
we asked nine AG's we saw their if they
attended and only three would confirm
they went
here's Arkansas AG Leslie Rutledge who
is the chair of raga when we asked her
staff if she was there they responded we
have nothing additional we got a hold of
the agenda which included yoga on the
beach and a dolphin tour in attendance
representatives from Koch Industries Big
Tobacco payday lenders and the NRA over
four days while their aides were back
home working we saw the AG's by the pool
playing golf and at open bar
oceanfront receptions all courtesy of
raga donors not bad for public servants
whose average salaries hover around 129
thousand dollars a year thank you very
much
you for supporting daga and it's not
just the Republicans Democratic AG's are
courted by trial lawyers at receptions
like this one in Washington and they to
take donations from companies under
investigation I think that really raises
some concerns about whether the AG's are
doing what they're supposed to be doing
which is represent their state and the
people of their state as opposed to
representing their biggest donors ragga
told us in a statement quote the
Republican attorneys general Association
has been successful in supporting
candidates that will defend the rule of
law Republican attorneys general have
this mindset and that's what drives
their actions nothing else the
Democratic attorneys general told us
that they quote do the right thing by
the law and for the people of their
states on a number of issues but you
know even if all that is true it still
makes you think about who can afford to
get this special access to top law
enforcement officials and who can't the
optics are really unfortunate I think
when people talk about the swamp this is
the kind of interaction that they're
imagining happening unfolding very
nice-looking swamp though out there
great golfing on swamp multiple times a
year by the way these happen quarterly
they wear a resort casual because they
have deeper pockets Nancy thanks for
that